Phần đột quan này mình đang thiếu khá là nhiều dữ liệu
Đầu tiên là dữ liệu ở bên dưới này, thiết bị gần đây cũng thiếu người phụ trách và chỉ lần cuối
Mọi thứ khác là được thiếu nha, sau mồi đến phần trưa bàn giao đang để là 100 m thì nó đang sai
Thu vị không phải là do người phí ôm, mà là do hình thống hẹn thống xếp lên, khi mà đạt 75%, cũng trên 75%, thì khu hào thì sẽ tự động rất là thu vị.
Nhưng cũng trên 15% thì khu hào thì sẽ tự động rất là thú vị
Ở phần thiết bị chỗ lành thiết bị thì đang không nhìn thấy là bình tĩnh sạch trí tiết thua vồi bảo trì
Bình tĩnh sạch đáy nhưng mà bấm vào thì không có gì thể đuổi cả
Một tùy chọn này thì hãy để là tất cả xong rồi ở bên dưới thì mình sẽ để là những cái chia lái
Tại vì đang thấy là để một tùy chọn xong rồi để tất cả bên dưới nhìn chung có vị sai
Chẳng thái mình chỉ có 5 chẳng thái là đang đã sẵn sàng
Bọn xong mình để tất cả bên dưới nhìn trông nó bị sai
Chẳng thái mình chỉ có 5 chẳng thái là
Đang
Đã sẵn sàng
Đã bàn rau
Đã bảo chi và
Đang kiểm kê cũng là
Đã thương vị
Hồ sơ người dùng này thì sẽ là danh sách
Quản lý sẽ là người xem được cái danh sách
Hồ sơ người dùng
dành kiểu như là thông tin của các nhân viên khác ấy
Ở phần quản lý đơn hàng
Ở phần quản lý đơn hàng thì cái chỗ loạn chi tiết ấy
thì mình cho cái phần sửa mấy cao vị ra ngoài đi
Xong rồi để cầm nhật trận thái ở ngoài luôn
Ở phần trước ấy
Ở cái trận cầm nhật trận thái mình sẽ trâu hẳn lên trên luôn
Xong rồi thì sẽ ở bên dưới chỉ là
tích bào là V hay là
Xong rồi để phần chi tiết là cái sửa và hủy sang bên cạnh kìa đây
Thao tác nhé, nhớ đề nhớ phải đề tên này một lần với trên đấy nhé
Chỗ phần tạo phiếu mới thì mình có đào lại phiếu bàn lao thu hồi và sửa chữa
Thì ở đây nói đến các loại phiếu này thì các thông tin các kiểu trong cái tạo phiếu mới đang sai nhé
Thì nó đang thiếu hông tin cũng phải xem trong cái bản giao này, cái bản thu hồi, với cả cái bản sửa trữa thì nó đã có các chứa hiệu để mình biết là những cái nào cần được nhập vào nhá.
Chỗ phần tạo phiếu mới thì mình có đào lại phiếu, phiếu bản giao, thu hồi và sửa trữa thì ở đây nói đến các loại phiếu này thì các thông tin các kiểu trong cái tạo phiếu mới đang sai nhá.
nhá. Nó đang chiếu hông tin cũng phải xem trong cái bản bàn dao này, cái bản hồi với cả cái bản sửa chữa thì nó đã có các chứa liệu để mình biết là những cái nào cần được nhập vào nhá.
Ở cái phần bàn dao và thu hồi thì tôi hy vọng là sẽ được phách hẳn ra rõ ràng hôn là chỗ nào là bàn dao chỗ nào là thu hồi
Vì, bặc dù là giống nhau, nhưng mà cái bàn giao thì nó chỉ là không có khi chú cái phần tình trạng của thiết bị sau khi thu hồi.
Phần thu vị nó có một cái tình trạng của thiết bị sau khi thu hồi, thì mình cái rõ cái đấy ra.
Và nó cũng phải được có chỗ để cập nhật nữa với kỹ thuật viên đấy.
Nên viên sẽ người cập nhập cái thông tin này mà
nên là phải có chỗ để trí thuật viên cập nhật thông tin
Ở phần của lý bầu chi thì mình sẽ có 2 cái là quả bảo chi định kỳ và sửa chúa
Thì trong bảo chi định kỳ sẽ có lập lập kế hoạch bảo chi mới
Còn trong sửa chúa thì sẽ chỉ là cái...
những cái phíu yếu cầu sửa chúa của bên nhân viên
Sau khi mà được duyệt thì nó sẽ đến đây
Chứ mình không có tạo phíu sửa chúa mới
Nó từ dưới nó qua đá vào không?
Ngoài ra thì cái phần mà từ cái đoạn mà tứ ấn vào để xem cái sửa trữa hay là một cái định kế thì khi mình tập cấp nhận này thì tình hình đang thiếu cái thông tin là
phíu này là ai là người tạo cái phíu sửa chữa này, phíu cổ sửa chữa này và ai là người duy nhất cái phíu với cổ sửa chữa này
đây đang thiếu 2 cái thông tin đấy
mình chú ý xem ở trong cái trường đữ lệ ổi thì có nghĩa thầy cô sẽ khá là coi kỹ mấy cái phần này
vì nếu mà nó không khóc với nhau thì kiểu rất là lộn rằng là mình không làm ấy
Ở cái đoạn đoạn cuối thì mình cứ đúng như cái vai mình kia ấy
Mình để là hoặc là xoả thùm ra về xoả thôi chứ không cần mình y rõ ra là là cái gì?
Ok nhá
Ở cái phần ít nhật kỳ sửa chữ thì mình không cần phải tạo ra một cái con ở ngoài đâu
Mà nó là nằm ở bên trong quần sửa chữ
Khi mà cái đoạn mà mình, khi mà danh sách chi tiết của thiết bị đấy rồi
thì mình có thể là mình đã xem lại nhật ký của cái thiết bị đã được sửa trưởng như thế nào, và cập nhận là trong đấy luôn.
Thì với phần kiểu kỷ định kỳ thì những cái kết quả thực tế,
kết quả kiểu kê là hình như là đang sai thì phải.
Với cần là kế hoạch kiểu kê thì nó phải...
Nó mặc là có thông báo là kiểm kê lùi nhưng mình không có cái bản nào để mình nhập cái thông tin của thiết bị
Đấy các thiết bị kiểm kê vào thì làm sao mà mình biết được
Ở phần thu hủy thiết bị thì hiện tại là đang sai hết cả các mấy cái khủng hao bên dưới giám mô bên dưới đang sai
Kiếp lại nhìn vào bên trong các bản hữu liệu ấy
Ở trên người kia rồi cậu sửa lại nhé
Nếu là phần thú vị thì nó sẽ là đề xuất thú vị
Đề xuất thú vị thì nó sẽ tạo một cái đề xuất thú vị ở đây hay là yêu cầu thú vị
Thì đấy, mình phải dựa trên những ngày này nó đúng với bên người vụ thì mới đúng được
Là phần bọc cáo, bọc cáo thì bọc cáo hiện tại đang chỉ bọc cáo tùng hợp
Chưa thấy trên này có hiện báo cáo tổng hợp
Nó mình có làm mới, mình nghĩ lại nữa thì nó cũng không có hiện gì bất kì gì
Và những cái như là báo cáo tuyên trạng thiết bị, tạm báo cáo hay là sốt, các kiểu gì nó cũng đang không có trạy như bình thường
Còn cái bảo trì theo loại hay là mấy cái yêu cầu bên dưới đây có vẻ là đang không khốc với phần trên
Trong phần báo cáo, chỉ có báo cáo, không có trạng thái thiết bị khúc ha và chỉ còn tồn tại là ở đâu nhá
Cậu sẽ cố gắng gột vào một cái bên trong cái này để mình lúc bà xuất thì nó sẽ ok hơn
Nếu phần phân quyền thì nhân viên
Kí thật viên này sẽ chỉ có phần bảo trì định kỳ và sửa chữa, cộng với phần kiểm kê
Vẫn sẽ là quản lý khi bảo trì có 1 con là bảo trì định kỳ sửa chữa
và 1 kí kiểm kê có 1 con là kiểm kê định kỳ ở bên dưới đây thôi
Xong với cả hồ quản lý hồ sâu người dùng thì ở cái chỗ
hồ sâu ở chỗ phần bùi mật khẩu đang sất ra kiểu là ok rồi
Không cần phải thêm đấy ở bên ngoài nữa
Thì đấy, thì đối với mỗi kiểu viên thì chỉ xem được, chỉ có được xem 2 cái là
tổng quan, phiếu yếu cầu, quản lý màu chi, quản lý trùm cây.
Còn với nhân viên thì nhân viên sẽ chỉ tạo phiếu yếu cầu thôi.
Xong rồi sẽ được xem phiếu yếu cầu với nước việt chưa?
Ơm... bầu chi...
Ơ không, không bầu chi
Quét mươi rồi, nãy mình chung vào tất cả cái này, đừng có quét mươi rồi
Tụi kéo, chụp tụi tí, tụi đau
Mấy phái